à la facebook non seulement ils
espionnent nos moindres faits et gestes
connaît nos opinions nos contacts nos
adresses localisation mais en plus il
laisse proliférer tout un tas de
contenus offensants et dangereux en
refusant de les réguler il n'y aurait
pas une petite contradiction
je vous explique en mars 2018 facebook
est accusé d'avoir joué un rôle dans
l'élection de donald trump le lanceur
d'alert christopher wilde et ancien
collaborateur de cambridge analytique à
une société de conseil spécialisée dans
la politique qui a oeuvré pour le compte
de donald trump pendant la campagne
présidentielle américaine de 2000 16
révèle que cambridge analytica avait
utilisé via facebook une application
développée spécifiquement qui lui
permettaient d'accéder aux données
personnelles de dizaines de millions
d'utilisateurs américains de facebook
sans leur consentement gros scandale
chute spectaculaire en bourse
facebook présente de plates excuses et
acceptent de se soumettre à un audit sur
le respect des droits civiques au sein
de sa plate forme
bon les conclusions de cet audit
viennent de tomber
facebook ne censure pas assez les
contenus offensants et louis et depuis
plusieurs semaines des centaines
d'annonceurs se met à le boycotter lui
reprochant de ne pas suffisamment
combattre la haine en ligne en plein
mouvement black light bearer de défense
des droits des noirs
le rapport demande vigoureusement exige
ordonne à facebook de faire davantage
pour lutter contre les discours de haine
la désinformation notamment autour des
élections et les discriminations liées à
la race au genre à l'orientation
sexuelle ou à la religion les auditrices
7 qui ont mené l'audit lorada boyoud
mains fines ancienne dirigeante de
l'association américaine de défense des
libertés est mégane kaka est une avocate
du cabinet brown kofax fustige facebook
parce qu'il laisse passer certains
messages de trump considéré soit comme
trompeur quand il explique que le vote
par correspondance favorise la fraude
soit comme appelant à la violence quand
il menace de tirer sur les pillards dans
les manifestations contre le racisme
contrairement à twitter qui a signalé
les tweets de trump avec une petite
vignette facebook a choisi de les
laisser tel quel par ce que il considère
que c'est l'avis de trump que ça fait
partie de sa liberté d'expression voilà
les gens peuvent être d'accord ou pas
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs fin 2019 mark
zuckerberg a fait un discours à
l'université georgetown à washington
dans lequel il dit refuser d'être un
arbitre de la vérité et faire voeu de
défendre la liberté d'expression mais
pour les autres east de l'audit
il s'agit d'un tournant inquiétant
prioriser la liberté d'expression par
rapport à toutes les autres valeurs
comme l'égalité et la non-discrimination
est profondément dérangeant
il faut avoir le droit de dire ce qu'on
pense sauf qu'on n'a pas le droit de
dire encore une fois on se heurtent au
même problème la liberté d'expression
sur internet doit elle être totale
surtout aux états unis qui sont quand
même champion en la matière ou doit-elle
être régulée à défaut d'être contrôlés
afin de ne pas heurter certaines
sensibilités de plus en plus à fleur de
peau dans une époque en pleine mutation
la liberté des uns s'arrête là où
commence celle des autres en tout cas
marc zuckerberg
saluant touche une sans faire bouger
l'autre comme disait chirac nous ne
changerons pas notre politique à poser
une menace représentant une petite
partie de notre chiffre d'affaires les
annonceurs reviendrons bientôt il ya
deux semaines chute spectaculaire avec
le boycott des annonceurs
mais maintenant l'action est reparti à
la hausse comme jamais à effacer toutes
ses pertes
et sa capitalisation boursière s'élève
aujourd'hui à près de 700 milliards de
dollars
voilà voilà